[Music]
so you want to venture into the dark
zone well there's a lot of good reasons
to go there weekly assignments have a
portion that needs to be completed in
the dark zone it's currently and has
always been the area in the game with
the best gear drop rates due to the high
concentration of named NPCs and chests
around and this includes classified gear
it's the best place to farm division
tech even with the updates coming out
soon outside of the dark zone you can
really only get dev tick through the
daily and weekly missions and through
dismantling gear the dark zone also
offers a good change to running the same
missions over and over of course there's
one thing that hinders the happy farmer
from effortlessly running through the
dark zone taking advantage of all of
these perks
ROK's this is a beginner's guide for
farming the dark zone solo but this can
also be applied to a group I won't be
talking about PvP in this video just
what you can do to get the most out of
the dark zone while avoiding other
players as much as possible before
diving in one of the biggest things you
need to get your head around is that
whatever drops whatever you find in the
dark zone that needs to be placed into
your contamination bag isn't yours until
you manage to extract it until it's
safely attached and flying into the
distance underneath the helicopter
anyone has the chance to be able to take
it from you once you understand this
you'll have a better time trust no one
treat every player as if they're about
to turn on you even that solo player
running around minding his own business
has the potential to catch you off guard
and gun you down before you can react
and if you're there to farm you're
likely running a PvE build so you
probably won't stand a chance
I'm a I'll just [ __ ] Ricky you
[ __ ] suck scrub your trash she
understood a game just go back to 490 I
didn't lose it that's a fairly typical
reenactment of a rogue encounter but in
the interests of keeping this a more
positive place for the remainder of this
video we'll just tidy up the language a
little bit so you may need to read
between the lines a little feelings it's
cool if you want to team up with players
and farm more effectively but play it
smart
don't tell them if you manage to get
something amazing and just be prepared
for them to potentially take anything
you may get it's not uncommon for
players to invite others into their team
just to boot them and kill them just
before extracting effectively making you
a mule to carry more gear
a large part of successfully farming the
dark zone is knowing the map but this
will take some time in repetition
don't try and learn every area to start
with just focus on a couple of zones for
example DZ 3 & 4 are a pretty good place
to start 1 & 2 are a little bit easier
but this is quite often where the rogue
groups will roam being comfortable with
your surroundings will help you both
with anticipating what's happening in
front of you and how to get away from
potential threats for example if you are
to come across this area and the NPC's
aren't here it's safe to assume that
another player or players are nearby
same goes if you find chests that have
already been looted because we're here
for farming and not PvP knowing where to
run when needed is quite important you
want to make sure you're not running
straight into a bunch of NPCs that will
slow you down or maybe if you're feeling
up to it you do want to run towards NPCs
and then turn on the Rogues will have
been fired at from all angles and at
this point it's worth noting that in the
dark zone you're gonna die to start with
you're gonna die a lot but this doesn't
matter you may lose some Garry if you're
carrying but if not you lose nothing so
use this if you need to sacrifice
yourself in order to successfully
extract gear do it or maybe you just
feel like finding a faster way to the
checkpoint
if you're heading into the dark zone to
farm division Tech there's two ways you
can go about this firstly there's dove
tech chests these are located all over
the dark zone and look like this once
opened this goes straight into your
pouch no need to extract so if you get
jumped and dropped you lose nothing but
farming division tech this way is slow
you only get one piece purchased a
better method is to found these chests
while also collecting gold caches these
are everywhere they drop often but the
best way to click them is to open these
chests the ones that don't require a key
they'll award you with a gold cache that
when opened will contain gear but also
between 2 and 5 division tech however
these need to be extracted use
extraction sites that you're comfortable
with you need to know all of the entry
and exit points when you first throw it
the extraction the entire map is aware
of it
so you've effectively alerted anyone in
the near vicinity of what you're up to
once the extraction has started
immediately run to find some cover NPCs
will spawn but don't shoot them they
play an important role for the solo
player if they aren't alluded to your
presence the NPC's will run out towards
the extraction and just stand there
talking amongst themselves so if anyone
else comes up to check the extraction
the NPCs will be your early warning sign
if you're hiding away the player will be
busy dealing with them assuming whoever
has started it has run off giving you a
chance to run away to help hide you
further I recommend that you always run
conceal a pulse in the dark zone if no
one shows up to the extraction believe
it until is about 30 seconds left on the
departing timer before attaching your
loot and this brings me to another point
when extracting particularly if you have
something that you really want make sure
that you have a full bag because if you
get killed with the full bag a portion
vertol drop is public and the wrist is
private-public anyone can pick up
private only you can see it so the
reason I recommend leaving the
extraction until the last 30 seconds is
because if you get killed you'll lose
some items if you attach it to the rope
and they cut the rope you'll lose
everything
if you're just wanting a change from the
usual missions and incursions the dark
zone is a good place to farm there's a
huge concentration of named enemies most
with Allah purchased close by both the
bosses and chests have a chance of
dropping classified gear plus as an
added bonus if you clear the landmarks
which are the purple areas on the map
you'll be given extra credits division
tech and gear that you don't need to
extract you need to be cautious when
farming landmarks because when they're
cleared they'll appear gray on the map
so players looking for some PvP will
often look out for this and can often
predict your next move based on the
landmarks you've cleared so far there
are two types of events in the dark zone
contamination vents and supply drops
contamination events are based
underground contaminations levels will
rise and then lower to the point where
you're able to enter it starts with
contamination levels rising
then contamination levels critical and
then a few minutes later contamination
levels lowering this is when you can go
in you'll still be heard over time but
it's more manageable make sure you have
good healing and all sustainability
after killing a bunch of NPCs and named
bosses you'll be awarded would loot
directly into your inventory and other
drops to collect supply drops are above
ground and a crates that are dropped in
areas that are marked on the map
much like extractions when opening a
Supply Drop chest players nearby are
alerted but if you manage to open it the
drops go directly into your inventory no
extraction required this is one of those
situations where putting your body on
the line is with it in order to open up
that chest I've lost count of the amount
of times that have been fighting off the
NPC's surrounding the Supply Drop
just to have a single player runnin and
quickly secure the drop right in front
of me
these are just a few tips on top of all
mentioned so far when running down the
street stick to the sides don't just run
wildly down the middle even if you
aren't being chased break the line of
sight keep obstacles in front and behind
you keep an eye on the kill feed if you
take nothing else away this is one of
the most important tips the feed will
not only tell you that stuff is going
down but also how far away they are
I actually prefer a server where I can
see rogues running around because I know
exactly we're a farm and we to extract
on the opposite end of the map if you're
finding that you're having no luck
change service to do this take note of
what's happening on the map
what extractions are going off what
landmarks are cleared and then matchmake
into an incursion or mission once joined
leave the group if the DZ map is
different you've changed service turn on
your void
I always did against this due to the
saltiness and ridiculous abuse being
thrown out there by every 10 to 13 year
old with a mic but with it turned on you
can often hear these players coming from
blocks away particularly on console if
you're having trouble getting
extractions completed due to players
constantly showing up throw out some
fake ones there's a couple of ways you
can do this pop an extraction and run
away to another extraction point or pop
an extraction wait let the players come
and go and then throw up another one
most will get sick of this eventually
and stop paying attention to them
last but not least if you're in a
situation where players show up while
you're clearing a landmark or Supply
Drop or even if you join in and help
others take MPC's down if you're worried
about getting jumped leave the gear on
the ground and don't pick it up it'll
last for quite a long time so just leave
it there and move on you can always come
back later and get it
the dark zone is an ugly place for a lot
of players and this isn't without reason
but it needs to be seen as a high-risk
high-reward area if you're being ganked
by players over and over move to the
opposite end of the DZ if they follow
you change service even with the rogue
risk the dark zone is large enough to
take advantage of the higher gear drop
rate and detect looting you just need to
play it smart for me the dark zone is
both the most intriguing and toxic part
of the division it's like a great big
social experiment yet I can't get enough
before I end this video I'm gonna ask
two things of you the viewer firstly if
you've made it this far
let me know in the comments by saying
purple monkey dishwasher I don't know
why it was the first thing that came to
mind and secondly please thank my mate
Mattel akane for his help the one that's
been reenacting the rope portion of this
video
he's the poor bastard that I call upon
when I want to test a new build okay
she's in the face metallic Ain has
recently started up his own YouTube so
if you guys can do me a solid and show
your support by checking out his channel
that'd be awesome let him know I sent
you it should be on the screen but all
places link in the description below
otherwise hopefully you've learned a
thing or two here and if you see me in
the dark zone don't be afraid to shoot
me in the face but I'll be expecting it
Cheers second piece of well the best
part of your mama's League okay give it
trailer pack your Atari
I get closed off and your dog gets
syphilis gonna have a cat oh you big
nosed unbroken do it monster
you